if you're very very high IQ there's some
evidence that suggests that it's
actually very hard to be successful kids
who are very smart literally have needs
that are different from the average kid
if we look at our school system School
moves at the pace of the slowest child
schools are not places where we take
kids and we try to have them live up to
their fullest potential so the system is
sort of designed to take the worst
performing kids and kind of like make
sure they're doing okay and this is what
tends to happen with kids who are super
smart is that they get bored with school
if if you're a kid who does really well
in school and you're not challenged you
don't develop study habits what happens
is you're at the top of your class in
the first grade second grade third grade
fourth grade fifth grade sixth grade
seventh grade you hit high school and
now suddenly you need to study and you
haven't developed any study habits and
you literally do not know how to study
so what you'll see is this like tanking
of GPA for kids who have high IQ